this is the largest thing that you've
worked can be represent your five in any
limb inclination how much the angrily
like off from the horizontal is it how
you it's really easy right
or you crazy so I want to have a look at
this guy or this interval Radha can feed
our equals now let's have a look I've
given you a pair of coordinates which
one would you like to be x1 y1 oh sure
why not x1 y1 which like this go down
here x2 y2 so if they start to rehearse
I'm going to have a look at my gradient
formula is y2 minus y1 do you agree with
that is the right Yes good again by the
way I'll just point out that's going to
be negative why is it maybe this cousin
table too slow it's sloping down to see
that it's not rising at all if some it's
dropping it so it's not negative right
ok what's the one not the value what am
I gonna put in the pressure on money
it's going to be five take away zero
salt on that in front like so so if I
just simplify a teeny bit that's what
I'd get what now can be armed it with
that but I want feet up not ten piercing
rich for you calculator you say shift n
K inverse and then you supply this
number now I want you to notice what
happens when you press equals it someone
giving another
okay yes it is always 10 I should work
now K is said to us and I appreciate
counties and Confirmation you're a
negative angle and it's a thirty eight
to test yes I'm getting too excited
now hold on this is weird
victory number one negative since when
what angles negative how are you
supposed to measure that secondly look
back in your definition to the angle of
information look back at the definition
for Sita so again I have done it I
haven't written down the answer you'll
see once you've worked out the angle in
here right well we want which angle
where the angle I work the real Tina
it's with the positive and angle x-axis
right over here this is clearly not
thirty eight point five nine whatever
places external okay that able to its of
choose isn't it to have a look at this
this angle is important it's just not
the one I want
what is this angle it's the other one
and that's where it's negative do you
see that look it's negative could it's
not in the right spot
look it's going down underneath the
action straight it's thirty eight point
five six nine that way not that way so I
need this angle thirty eight point five
six nine dot dot dot how is that
connected to the angular 1
yeah it's just the supplement isn't it
so I'm actually gonna write not this but
okay a hundred and eighty degrees minus
that
[Music]
Vegas okay
so just coming back to where we were and
someone worked out 180 minus thirty
eight point not aa is someone that one
forty one points or not in this case
you could do one or two means you can
round it off to the news degree pretty
easily but often do you guys as five
three students will be asked to convert
to the nearest minute rather than the
nearest degree so you need to look for
this button you know the fun this is the
degrees minutes seconds bottom will
change to plus usually when you like
what is it that you're changing to a
cloth the ATM and we're easy to well
these angle he is said a quick budget
countries on but the angle I want is 180
minus them so I'm just going to leave it
and someone presents degrees minutes
seconds and hook me up and you may not
the entire just like a wheel victory yep
25 minutes and a second are to
complicate them okay if you a point okay
now I'm right on the whole thing to you
just to maybe no degree in a second ours
is confusing right does anyone know one
minute scored minutes because they are
my mute which means small okay does
anyone know why seconds are called
second because it's the second my new
division of angles of hours whatever the
ease that your deductive dividing okay
now that's Greece
how many minutes in a degree there are
60 minutes in a degree just like there
are 60 minutes in an hour how many
seconds are there in a minute there are
60 seconds in a minute just like four
angles as it is the time surrounding
here is a little bit different you have
to be careful um 25 still okay still
round down tougher than 41 as the
original line told you but let's round
it up to the nearest minute counts this
is 141 degrees and 26 26 minutes 120
degrees because that's clearly closer to
a whole minute because 726 let's write
to the nearest finish yet how do you
think existed